this episode is brought to you by
curiositystream get free access to
nebula the streaming service built by
all your favorite youtubers when you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below
[Music]
vice espn and the history channel what
do these three media outlets have in
common
despite their different target audiences
they're all owned by the same company
disney what about these three same story
they're all owned by comcast if you were
to pick a bunch of media operations from
a hat
odds are the vast majority of them are
owned and operated by one of just five
mega corporations
since the early 1980s the number of
media companies controlling the bulk of
us media has shrunk from 50 to just
five we've gone from a media landscape
operated by a reasonable number of
controlling interests to a reality
dominated by near monopolies
just barely sneaking under the
enforcement of anti-trust laws
in this episode we're going to talk
about the consolidation of american
media in the hands of a few
ultra powerful companies and what that
means in a time when the very wealthy
have outsized influence over public
policy
before we begin it's worth noting that
corporate deals acquisitions and mergers
happen all the time
often with little to no coverage it's
quite possible that by the time you
watch this video
some of these data points will have
changed but unless something truly
cataclysmic happens the vast majority of
us media will still be under the thumb
of one or more of the five super
corporations we're about to discuss
so without further ado let's meet the
big five comcast
disney national amusements news corp and
at t
taking the spot from time warner which
it acquired in 2018 for 109 billion
dollars
you probably guessed that disney was on
the list since they've had some
seriously high profile
acquisitions in recent years most
notably marvel and lucasfilm
but i'd be surprised if you've ever
heard of national amusements or news
corp
these incredibly bland names and their
lack of public-facing operations are
intentional
why draw attention to yourself as one of
a tiny number of corporate behemoths
when people only care about a select few
of your properties
whether you're watching cbs news
scrolling through gamespot or reading a
book published by simon
schuster you're patting the enormous
wallet of national amusements
and you'd never suspect that these three
very different operations are run by the
same company
the same goes for news corp they own
national geographic fox news and
harpercollins
altogether the big five are worth over
400 billion dollars
controlling something like 90 percent of
all u.s media including news networks
hollywood movie studios and print
publications
and they reach nearly 100 of all u.s
households
and fun fact much of the remaining 10 is
owned by only slightly less giant
multi-billion dollar corporations like
sinclair
which as you may remember got itself
into hot water by blasting out a
propaganda broadcast over hundreds of
local us news channels
so how exactly are they allowed to do
this surely having just five companies
dominate the nation's media is
considered monopolizing right
well no but just barely let's look at
what it takes to be considered a
monopoly
in order to be considered a pure
monopoly a single company has to have
complete control over a market
containing a good or service with no
close substitutes
so there you go since there are five
large corporations that share the us
media market
none of them qualify as a monopoly but
you don't have to be classified as a
pure monopoly in order to wield
monopolistic power with such a massive
concentration of wealth and power in the
hands of so few
it all but ensures that smaller
operations never have the chance to
succeed
unless you count the very american
concept of success which is building a
company just large enough to get bought
out by one of the big players
what we see in the u.s media landscape
is more of an oligopoly
complete control spread across just a
handful of powerful groups
there's so much interplay and
deal-making within these five
mega-corporations that in effect they
are a monopoly in every sense but the
legal one for example
it's not uncommon to see one of the big
five hold a massive stake in a property
owned by another of the big five
but if there were so many more media
corporations as recently as the 1980s
how did we get to the dystopian
all-powerful corporate landscape we see
today
to make a long story short it all boils
down to the passing of the 1996
telecommunications act
this piece of legislation was supposedly
intended to deregulate the increasingly
tangled broadcast and telecommunications
markets
allowing anyone to enter and compete in
the industry whatever the intended
result was
the actual outcome was simply the rapid
consolidation of power in the hands of
fewer and fewer massive corporations
in the 2003 edition of howard zinn's a
people's history of the united states he
notes
the telecommunications act of 1996
enabled the handful of corporations
dominating the airwaves to expand their
power further
mergers enabled tighter control of
information he was right
and it only got worse the decade before
the telecommunications act
50 companies controlled the majority of
the media landscape by 1992
that number had fallen by 50 percent and
after the passage of the new tv and
broadcast legislation the number quickly
shrank even further
to just six in the year 2000 and that's
roughly where it stayed to this day not
because these giant companies wouldn't
love to own more of the market
but because they physically can't
without triggering anti-trust lawsuits
to put in perspective just how much of
the market the big five control
let's have a look at some of the media
operations they own we'll start with
news corp
rupert murdoch's empire owns fox
including all of its branches like fox
sports and 20th century fox
it owns fx gq the wall street journal
sky
news harpercollins publishing the new
york post national geographic
zondervan market watch and countless
others national amusements owns cbs and
its branches it owns paramount
nickelodeon
mtv bet gamespot vh1
comedy central the smithsonian channel
spike showtime simon schuster game faqs
cnet and viacom once a major player in
the media world itself before being
consumed
a t the newest member of the big five
after acquiring the massive time warner
controls cnn hbo cartoon network warner
brothers
dc tbs truetv cinemax tnt
adult swim part of hulu turner classic
movies time magazine
rocksteady games and time warner cable
to name just a few
comcast which has a well-deserved
reputation as a thoroughly evil
corporation
owns nbc msnbc usa network
sci-fi fandango universal pictures focus
features
working title films rotten tomatoes
bravo oxygen big idea part of hulu
mlb network nhl network and dozens of
internet ventures
and finally everyone's favorite
family-friendly corporate overlord
disney disney owns abc pixar
dreamworks espn lifetime the history
channel
marvel lucasfilm hollywood records
touchstone pictures
vice plus a giant swath of the comic
book industry thanks to their
acquisition of marvel
and of course these are only a small
sample of the media operations owned by
the big five
odds are if you can think of a network
you watch you'll find it's owned by one
of them the one main exception you may
have noticed is netflix
netflix while not outright owned by any
of the big five
is owned in part by a number of large
interests some of them very shady like
the well-known blackrock the world's
largest shadow bank
so really no matter what your network
preferences you're only being offered
the illusion of choice
in reality almost everything we watch or
read whether on tv
online in theaters or on the pages of a
book newspaper or magazine
is just a tentacle of the enormous
kraken that is the corporate media
landscape
no matter what perspectives these
outlets offer remember that they're all
owned by the same ultra wealthy business
interests
and they have their own agenda the big
five own all the major news networks and
the messages they put out are designed
to reinforce the status quo
peddling minor aesthetic disagreements
and diverting attention away from
serious societal problems
this is simply the natural conclusion of
the hyper-capitalist system we have in
the united states
powerful companies will grow larger and
larger consuming smaller companies that
can't compete
acquiring more and more properties until
they've reached the very limit of what
could be considered legal
thereby dodging anti-trust laws and
maintaining the maximum amount of power
profit and cultural significance and
this is only one area of the american
market
every other aspect of american life is
becoming similarly consolidated from
pharmaceuticals to energy to
manufacturing
the threat of the monopolization of
every area of modern life is real
and its consequences could be disastrous
and far-reaching
except for those pulling the strings at
the very top
if you've watched my last few videos
you'll have noticed that youtube has
been demonetizing a lot of them
that's why some of my creator friends
and i teamed up to build nebula a
streaming platform built by and for
youtubers like me so we don't have to
worry about demonetization
since nebula is all about creating
thoughtful content we've partnered with
curiositystream
an established streaming platform with a
solid track record of caring about great
educational content
and the financial security of those who
produce it curiosity stream is an online
streaming service with thousands of
non-fiction titles from some of the best
filmmakers in the game
you can find tons of great episodes like
american icons walt disney
which is a great quick watch if you
enjoyed this week's video as educational
creators ourselves we love curiosity
stream
so we've worked out a deal where if you
sign up for curiosity stream at the link
below you'll also get access to nebula
100
free for a limited time curiosity stream
is offering 26
off their annual plan that's less than
15 bucks a year for both curiosity
stream and nebula
which in my humble opinion is a pretty
great deal since we're all stuck inside
anyway
why not spend some time watching
fascinating documentaries on curiosity
stream
or check out nebula's exclusive content
like real engineering's logistics of
world war ii series
you can also watch all my videos as they
were intended ad free
there really is something for everyone
and by signing up at the link below
you're helping us produce more content
without the fear of demonetization
give curiosity stream a shot and get
free access to nebula when you sign up
using the link below
it really does help support my channel
and educational creators all across
youtube
if you enjoyed this video and you'd like
to see more like it consider subscribing
to stay up to date with my latest
episodes
if you hated it go ahead and drop a
thumbs down you can check out my
previous episodes by clicking the links
on your screen
thanks for watching and i'll see you
next week